c'est une belle tradition qui nous vient
d'allemagne et qui se pratique depuis
plusieurs années en alsace dès que le
gel s'installe durablement les
viticulteurs récoltent le raisin givré
et il donnera plus tard un délicieux
vins liquoreux appelé vin de glace les
vendangeurs étaient à pied d'oeuvre ce
matin sous un beau soleil d'hiver
reportage sur place stéphanie la fuente
jean-pierre pasteur c'est un étrange
cortège un peu anachronique
à quatre jours de noël ce ne sont pas
des lutins mais bien des vendangeurs qui
se pressent sur les hauteurs de
soultzmatt ni le réveil matinal
il est à peine cette heure ni le froid
ne les ont découragés c'est bien entre
les gâteaux les chocolats et puis venir
vendanger ça ça fait vraiment un plaisir
en plus dans quelques minutes on va voir
le ciel soleil s'est levé le jour celui
ce sera parfait vous errez magnifique
depuis trois jours sur cette parcelle de
gewürztraminer le thermomètre titre - 7°
idéal pour le vin de glace car les
grains de raisins sont tout juste gelé
sous leur peau givré seul lot a
cristallisé reste le sucré l'acide qui
d'ici deux ans donneront à vins
liquoreux
une fois que l'eau est gelé ça fait que
le jeu est plus concentré et donc tout
le principe est tout le jeu consiste à
presser le raisin temps que l'eau est
jolie mais au delà de la
surconcentration il ya aussi des arômes
un peu spéciaux un peu du brûlés du chum
et qui vient de l'action du froid sous
le raisin à l'heure où certains sortent
à peine du lit ces vendangeurs de
l'hiver ont déjà fini leur travail
mais avant de rentrer à la caf pour
presser le raisin on prend le petit
déjeuner et comme nous sommes au milieu
des vignes ici café se dit vin chaud